antoine gayraud bonjour les hostilités
dont contre les forces arméniennes et
azerbaïdjanaises ont lieu depuis hier
matin et se poursuivent donc à l'heure
actuelle le long de la frontière de la
région contestée du haut karabagh
antoine comment la communauté
internationale a réagi tel à ce regain
de tension oui les combats continuent
malgré les nombreux appels au calme à la
retenue de plusieurs dirigeants les
états unis ou encore l'union européenne
ont appelé à la cessation immédiate des
hostilités la situation sur place a par
exemple été jugée très préoccupante par
le chef de la diplomatie européenne
josep borrell même son de cloche du côté
de l'élysée regarder chacun connaît la
proximité de la france avec le peuple
arménien il doit retrouver la paix au
plus vite la france sera toujours à ses
côtés
la france est prête à prendre toutes ses
responsabilités en tant que coprésidents
du groupe de minsk le président de la
république a appelé fermement à la
cessation immédiate des hostilités et
dit sa disponibilité à contribuer à un
règlement pacifique et durable de la
question du haut karabagh
la russie qui entretient de bonnes
relations avec à la fois l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan a offert un rôle de
médiateur et appelle elle aussi au calme
dans la région écouter il est important
de mettre en oeuvre tous les efforts
nécessaires pour éviter une escalade de
la confrontation mais l'essentiel est
qu'il faut mettre fin aux hostilités
alors on l'a entendu derrière l'arménie
et l'azerbaïdjan s'accusent mutuellement
d'avoir ouvert les hostilités l'arménie
qui on vient d'apprendre a saisi la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
demander des mesures provisoires contre
l'azerbaïdjan
mais il est important de souligner le
rôle en coulisses d'un autre acteur
régional la turquie écouter j'appelle la
communauté internationale à activer tous
les leviers afin de dissuader toute
intervention éventuelle de la turquie
qui déstabiliserait complètement la
situation dans la région
tout le cas par cas guy d'un
comportement agressif de la turquie qui
a été particulièrement dangereux lors
des événements de juillet et se poursuit
aujourd'hui est très préoccupant le
président turc qui vient d'ailleurs on
vient de l'apprendre qui vient de
demander la fin de l'occupation
arménienne du karabagh allié de bakou de
longue date ankara l'a bien fait savoir
qu'elle fera tout son possible pour lui
venir en aide
sous-entendu même une intervention
militaire n'est pas exclue regarder dans
ce processus la turquie soutient
pleinement l'azerbaïdjan avec une
solidarité indéfectible
nous serons aux côtés de l'azerbaïdjan
quelle que soit la manière dont ils le
souhaitent les efforts de la diplomatie
les efforts de la diplomatie
internationale ne seront pas de trop
pour empêcher une guerre ouverte entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan une guerre
jusque là larvée depuis près de 30 ans
un conflit aux enjeux locaux bien
entendu mais qui par procuration
pourrait déstabiliser bien plus que
cette région du monde